big cat i'll tell you what this is one
of those days where i was happy to stay
up late and watch the game because the
game was awesome and when the alarm went
off i jumped out of bed because i said i
can't wait to talk about this game for
three hours this morning you can't wait
to see my face i agree with you though
uh thursday night football was fantastic
doesn't it feel like
the seahawks this game
it feels like the seahawks have retooled
everything in our back you know
obviously they changed their entire
defense they went to the playoffs last
year
but that i know we talked about the
sound a lot at in seattle and how loud
it is but it really did feel like that
last night and winning that big game
against the rams and now we have a lot
of questions about the rams and i have a
lot of questions for you mike florio
well and the thing about the seahawks
when you retool that team when you
dismantle the legion of boom when you
build the team around quarterback
russell wilson and you give him 35
million dollars per year
you start to shift toward more offense
and that's what we saw last night and
russell wilson moved the ball all night
long he had a passer rating of the
evening
151.8 he's got 12 touchdown passes and
no interceptions through five games and
anytime it feels like he's gonna get
swallowed up by the rush he springs out
and makes something happen he had some
beautiful throws the i don't know what
was more impressive the throw to tyler
locket or the catch by tyler lockett
i i still don't know how tyler locker
caught that pass and i don't know how
russell wilson threaded the needle i
thought he was just throwing the ball
away
yeah and tyler lockett is the new doug
baldwin and by that i mean the guy who
russell wilson seems to find in those
exceptional places and exceptional ways
and when the chips are down and he's
scrambling around and running for his
life he always used to find doug baldwin
streaking down the field tyler lockett
feels like he's completely uh slipped
into that position there and you know
with doug baldwin stepping away from the
game but you're right russell wilson is
fantastic i think he's one of the best
quarterbacks in the nfl that's not
saying anything crazy i heard earlier
this week you might have said he's uh
people don't give him enough credit i
think people give him plenty of credit
no because everybody
listen everybody
he's very capable of coming up with your
own ideas he doesn't need to feed his
hot takes through you to give me a hard
time i know what he's up to and i don't
appreciate it i watch the show mike i
watch this show
here's the thing russell when we start
listing the upper echelon in the nfl
people do not put russell wilson in it
he's always that guy on the other side
of the best of the best he needs to be
in the best of the best he is in my best
of the best and this is one of those
situations mike you are the company that
you keep it sounds like you're hanging
around a bunch of morons because elsa
wilson is one of the top five
quarterbacks in the nfl and the
conversation should always be a brady
rogers mahomes russell wilson that
should be the you know whatever you want
to go one through four but he's in there
and i i you know i don't know who you're
hanging around but every time you see
russell wilson play you realize how
special he is the plays he makes the
other thing i wanted to talk about real
quick about this game mike and we can
get back to russell wilson if you want
but it's so funny how
you know that that quick with that win
that one point win for the seahawks
covers up some pretty bad coaching
decisions by pete carroll and the
seahawks staff the end of the half when
they get super conservative and they
don't go for it on fourth and one and
they miss a field goal and they play
prevent defense let the rams go
touchdown touchdown end the touchdown
first half start of t start a second
half get a touchdown and then when
they're when they need the first down
third and two to ice the game away and
they try to do something completely
different russell wilson almost throws
the game away when chris carson is
getting four and a half yards of carry
the seahawks in a victory we never
usually pick apart what the the
victorious team does but i thought their
play calling was a little suspect at
times and i'd be nervous about them
doing the conservative thing when they
should be a lot more aggressive with a
great running back than chris carson
yeah if you're watching on nbcsn you can
see the play now on third and two when
the seahawks were trying to ice the game
and the rams were set for a run up the
middle i thought it was going to be
something to the outside but not this
debacle and but for tyler lockett that
really is a disaster for the seahawks
and the rams maybe scoop it up and score
a touchdown right there and see that's
you know my my worry for the seahawks on
that that touchdown drive that put them
up 30-29 is they were inevitably gonna
leave too much time for the rams there
was not
enough real estate for them to chew up
to churn out the last nine minutes they
were going to leave the rams some time
on the clock and as it turns out they
left the rams enough time to to try
twice after that great interception by
tedrick thompson that was ruled
incorrectly on the field and i was
rooting for a pick six so the seahawks
would cover
the the seahawks all they needed was
that one first down and they almost blew
it with that ridiculous play on third
and short and you're right we forget
about that because it all worked out but
that would be the thing we're talking
about big cat if greg zerline doesn't
miss the 44-yard field goal the
ridiculous handling of that third down
play by pete carroll and the seahawks
right and i wanted to point that out
because if you remember last year when
the seahawks go to dallas for their
playoff game and the play calling by
brian schottenheimer and the seahawks
staff and how maddening it was to watch
what what we both agree on here is a top
five quarterback and russell wilson not
be able to make the plays because they
were consistently trying to run the
football last night they're able to run
the football the rams defense we can
talk about them they they are suspect
and i have concerns about them going
forward but the seahawks play calling
and the consistency do you have the
confidence in what they're going to do
week in and week out or when the big
moment happens because it it feels like
when you have fourth and one and you're
trying to be a running team and you
decide to kick the field goal instead of
get that one yard that's a little bit in
your own head when you have third and
two and you're a running team and you're
trying to get that first down and you do
this weird pitch play with russell
wilson that feels like you're getting in
your own head it's almost the reverse of
the criticism last year where everyone
was criticizing brian schottenheimer for
running the ball too much and not giving
russell wilson the chance to make plays
and now when he's in very clear running
downs where he should be able to get
those one and two yards they're
tightening up and they're doing
something different
yeah and if you have any doubt about
your ability in those spots to gain a
yard or two because the defense is going
to be ready for that
let russell wilson dance around a little
bit maybe find a guy open like they did
on the fourth down play when they scored
the touchdown that chris carson almost
dropped i mean let russell wilson start
moving with his legs and run it if he
needs to or throw it if he sees someone
wide open like he did on the touchdown
but you know that was a key play that
was a key moment where they they didn't
get inside their heads but i agree with
you on some of these other ones they're
trying to be a little too cute they're
trying to outsmart themselves and
they're getting away from the thing that
works and i think any play that you take
the ball out of russell wilson's hands
from the standpoint of a potential run
or pass decision that's when you're just
asking for a disaster if it's something
like that where this this weird pitch
play and
i it just the whole thing was bizarre
and it really would have killed the
knight for the seahawks it almost did
and and we'd have been destroying
schottenheimer and pete carroll and even
russell wilson russell wilson seemed
like he freaked out a little bit in that
moment too and it would have taken away
dramatically from what otherwise was a
special night for him
mike the other thing i wanted to talk to
you about are you thinking what i'm
thinking right now are you are we on the
same page are we on the same wavelength
i don't know we'll find out okay here's
here we go the clay matthews roughing
the passer terrible terrible call
we need instant replay for roughing the
passer mike florio the king of instant
replay we need instant replay let's add
more replay to the game it was a bad
call i don't think it decided the game
because it happened on uh on a first and
ten so it's not like you know the
seahawks were backed up and it was a
bailout call on third down but it was a
bad call and this is maybe a reputation
call because we saw it last year when
clay matthews fell on kirk cousins and
maybe it was even mike a makeup call for
clay matthews knocking the snot out of
russell wilson in 2015 in the nfc
championship game whatever you want to
say it was it was not good and we needed
to solve it and i know you're going to
overreact and tell us we need instant
replay
that is a delayed makeup call if that's
a makeup call that
of four years later that that's that's a
creative thought by you but here's the
problem and this is where the coaching
needs to come in
when you're going in to hit a
quarterback you gotta hit the strike
zone and if you even if you hit him with
your shoulder if you hit him high enough
when you jam him with your shoulder his
head's gonna jerk back as if he has been
hit in the helmet and if your helmet's
in the vicinity of his helmet it's gonna
look like you went helmet to helmet so i
don't know why they don't coach these
guys to lower not lower the helmet lower
the shoulder and hit him in the
midsection and then there's no doubt
because the strike zone on a quarterback
is knees to neck and if you let your
helmet stay high even if you go shoulder
to shoulder it may look like helmet to
helmet a couple of weeks ago there was
one camela correa of the titans
hit gardner minshew in the jaw with his
helmet the fox guys were complaining
about that but the replay made it clear
there was helmet to helmet contact last
night they were right there was not and
i don't look i i've been saying for
years these safety related rules the hit
on the defenseless player the roughing
the passer when you're talking about 15
yards of field position and a fresh set
of downs maybe you should have some sort
of a replay component because you you're
you know even though it was only first
down from second and 10 on the 40 to
first and ten on the 25 is a big deal in
that moment and i look they're not going
to get it right in real time if there's
a quick and easy way and this is where
the big red button would come into play
right we don't need replay we just need
the big red button we need the sky judge
we need somebody you advocated the big
red button with the mallet whack-a-mole
true it would have been easily fixed
because genius here's the thing here let
me tell you this the the tedrick
thompson interception last night
clear
obvious
no doubt
should have taken 25 seconds to overturn
it took like four minutes like they need
a device where they can make these
changes quickly based upon what we all
see at home i say this all the time big
cat the nfl's biggest problem right now
is the disconnect between what we all
see
in hd 25k whatever the hell it is and
what the officials who are out there
trying not to get trampled see at full
speed yeah and they need a way to bridge
that gap and replay review's not good
enough you're you're right on that the
the refs are definitely put in a bad
spot because we are you know experts in
these and getting to see a million
replays before they almost can even make
the call
listen rams fans aren't gonna like this
they'll probably be watching on the
replay so know that you're watching it
on the replay and i'm long gone from the
studio so don't complain to me but clay
matthews when you play with fire you're
gonna get burned and by that i mean
doesn't he seem like he's always in and
around the quarterback like very close
to when they're releasing the ball he
gives that little extra something a
little extra mustard on the hot dog if
you will and when you do that eventually
you will get burned you i think you
there was a play earlier in the game
where he either got called for the for
the rough and the passer or it was very
close where it was a little extra just
as the ball was being released or right
after the ball was being released and of
course there's something to that to try
to make the quarterback feel
uncomfortable to try to make the
quarterback know hey we're here and
we're going to keep coming all night but
that feels like clay matthews
i don't want to say a reputation because
i don't think he's a dirty player by any
means but when you play that physical
style of football right on the edge with
today's nfl that will burn you in key
spots and that's what happened again
with clay matthews last night you know
if there was no other proof that you are
now a father that is ultimate dad advice
know where the line is and stay the hell
away from it and that's all you need to
ever tell your son in any situation
figure out where the line is and if you
dance on it there's a chance somebody's
going to assume that you crossed it and
that's what happened to clay matthews
last night
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports